skipper says that planning for this
year's coverage started years ago taking
lessons from the 2010 World Cup games in
South Africa we applied a lot of lessons
we learned in 2010 and we just took it
up you know several notches right the
all of the documentaries we did all the
studio shows we did the amount of
international talent we just decided
everything that worked in 2010 will work
better because the time zone because of
Brazil and how special it is for soccer
because more people are coming to soccer
in this country our average television
rating is up 39 percent despite the fact
that that's up that much the digital
viewing has been through the roof
this will be is already the most
streamed sporting event of all time we
are now 70% beyond the Sochi Olympics we
will be more than double the Sochi
Olympics before this is over and that
with the previous high-water mark I want
to go through some of those numbers for
livestream right so over 3.3 million for
the US Germany match 3.5 million for the
u.s. Belgium at how do you capitalize on
that
we're already capitalizing on that
because of course those people who watch
there we are selling ads against those
folks those people will walk you sold
more I always wish we sold more I am
always in discussions with the ad sales
department but the only World Cup that
the selling rating should be higher no
effect they sold very aggressively and
of course this just means we're
delivering now it didn't go off without
some glitches though John as you know so
I checked out on Twitter look to see
what some people said is they were
live-streaming ESPN stream bad and
getting worse can we start a Kickstarter
campaign to by ESPN some more server
time well we don't need more server time
the I actually think it's remarkable
that given the volume of what we deliver
the the problems have been tiny we had a
little bit I'm sure that tweet came from
the USA Germany game when we had for a
very small number of people some
issues with the technical but 99.9% of
people have had a very good experience
now your log on with the next game and I
promise you it will look great and kudos
to our guys they've done a great job we
now can handle an enormous volume of
digital users we've served an enormous
number of videos during this we've
served a lot of fantasy or bracket
participants during this so we can
handle scale so you would say that you
were definitely well prepared you were
as prepared as you would have ever been
for all the people to click online oh
yes this it really has been you your
research is absolutely correct there
were some tweets but it's tiny we really
have our guys have done great here on
this does that mean that you can see
this sort of enthusiasm translating into
live streaming other kinds of sporting
events from here on out oh I don't think
there's any doubt that they I mean
there's well while we're proud of
setting the record this record will be
broken because people are getting used
to the idea that they can watch their
live games on whatever device they have
wherever they are under their control
and that's going to keep going on
because of the importance of watching
sporting events live now the World Cup
rights though you're not going to have
them in 2018 or 2022 you really are a
spoiler of the party here it was so fun
until now look we we are concentrating
on doing a great job here we're having a
great time it's a great event it's gonna
be a great event
and of course there'll be some there's
some regret and not having it but that's
that's that's the capitalist system and
we're gonna continue to participate in
it does it kind of make it a bittersweet
no I mean this is so fun and so great
and I've got a the production all of our
people are doing such a good job that
I'm just going to enjoy it right now I
don't think you need to be bittersweet
about it